resuelve el sistema de ecuaciones usando
cualquier método y nos dan igual a 2 x x
menos cuatro elevado al cuadrado más 3 y
ya igual a menos x cuadrada más 2 x
menos 2 así es que la solución puede
haber una solución puede no haber
solución pueden ser múltiples soluciones
pueden ser dos soluciones para un valor
dado de x si yo lo sustituyó en ambas
ecuaciones debo de obtener exactamente
el mismo valor de g en este sistema
podemos determinar los valores de x que
cumplen suponiendo que los valores de
jett tienen que ser iguales para las dos
ecuaciones con lo cual tenemos que esto
de aquí este valor de ley que es menos x
cuadrada más 2 x menos 2 tiene que ser
igual a este valor de acá a este otro
valor de y que es 2 que multiplica a x
menos 4 elevado al cuadrado más 3 y
ahora resolvamos esto para x así es que
el lado izquierdo bueno no vamos a tener
que desarrollar del lado derecho este
binomio al cuadrado así es que tenemos
que menos x cuadrada más 2 x menos 2 es
igual
a 2 que multiplica a x cuadrada menos 8
x 16 3 esto que es igual 2 x cuadrada
estoy distribuyendo el 2 menos 16 x 2 x
menos 8 x menos 16 x más 32 más 3 y esto
es igual a vamos a asociar términos
semejantes 2x cuadrada menos 16 x más 35
y por supuesto el lado izquierdo que no
hemos tocado que es menos x cuadrada más
2 x menos 2 y ahora ahora qué vamos a
hacer bueno es una ecuación cuadrática
así es que vamos a deshacernos de los
términos del lado izquierdo de un solo
jalón para esto vamos a sumar entonces x
cuadrada sumamos x cuadrada a ambos
lados de la ecuación restamos 2x a ambos
lados de la ecuación y sumamos 2 a ambos
lados de la ecuación hagamos esta suma
del lado izquierdo
este se cancela este se cancela este se
cancela nos queda 0 que es igual a 2x
cuadrada más x cuadrada es 3x cuadrada
menos 16 x menos 2x nos da menos 18 x y
finalmente 35
23737 ya está ya tenemos la ecuación
cuadrática igualada a cero podemos
aplicar la fórmula cuadrática para
resolverla así nuestras soluciones los
valores de x están dados por menos b
menos menos 18 18 positivos más menos la
raíz cuadrada de b cuadrada que es 18 al
cuadrado menos 4 veces el valor de a que
es 3
por el valor de s que es 37 y todo eso
dividido entre 2 a 2 por 36 calculemos
entonces cuánto es esto tenemos 18 más
menos la raíz de 18 al cuadrado vamos a
sacar la calculadora
18 al cuadrado es 324 menos 4
por 3 por 37 esto nos da menos 120 menos
120 podríamos haber intuido que esto es
negativo 4 por 3 es 12 por 37 es un
número mayor que 18 al cuadrado bueno no
está tan tan claro pero sí podría ser
sospechado que esté lo negativo que
vamos a hacer con esto que vamos a hacer
con esta raíz cuadrada de menos 120
sabemos que para los números reales no
hay valor que corresponda a la raíz
cuadrada de menos 120 por lo cual no hay
solución para esta ecuación cuadrática
sin
solución y de eso nos podemos dar cuenta
con el discriminante el discriminante es
esta cantidad de cuadrada menos 4 hace
que nos da negativa por lo cual la
ecuación no tuvo solución y en cuanto al
sistema de ecuaciones podemos por lo
tanto afirmar que no
solución al sistema no existen valores
de x que si los pones en estas
ecuaciones te den exactamente el mismo
valor de y consideremos un poco por qué
sucede esto esta de aquí es una parábola
que abre hacia arriba para la cual se
puede determinar directamente la
ubicación del vértice vamos a graficar
la por acá voy a hacer lo mejor posible
y gráfica vamos a poner aquí el eje y
y aquí el eje x
esta palabra tiene su vértice en
4,343 es una parábola que abre hacia
arriba el coeficiente el término
cuadrática es positivo así es que la
parábola viene aproximadamente no es
exacta más o menos más o menos así es la
parábola y esto como se ve es una
parábola que abre hacia abajo vamos a
llevar la ecuación a una forma donde
podamos determinar fácilmente el vértice
lo que vamos a hacerlo aquí abajo
tenemos la ecuación que es igual a voy a
factorizar el signo menos menos equis
cuadrada menos 2 x + 2
ahora vamos a agrupar estos términos
vamos a ponerlo así de la siguiente
manera que va a ser más fácil más 2 nos
separamos y ponemos x 4 menos 2 x vamos
a completar aquí el cuadrado menos 2
entre 2 es 1 elevado al cuadrado es 1 si
sumamos 1 restamos 1 para no alterar la
ecuación que tenemos ahora esto es igual
a x menos 1 al cuadrado
eso con el signo menos de fuera y no no
voy a quitar aún el paréntesis voy a
hacerlo paso a paso para no perder me va
a ser menos paréntesis x menos 1 al
cuadrado esto es menos uno más dos más
uno y esto iguala que ahora que vamos a
hacer vamos a escribir esto como ya
igual a menos x uno al cuadrado menos
uno ya está ya podemos determinar que el
vértice está en 1 coma menos 1 entonces
uno para la derecha 1 para abajo ahí
está el vértice de esta parábola que
abre hacia abajo por este signo menos lo
podemos determinar así es que la
parábola tendría más o menos más o menos
y es la gráfica de esta parábola como
puedes ver nos intersectan este vértice
está por arriba y es el punto mínimo de
una parábola que abre hacia arriba y se
encuentra por encima del vértice de esta
parábola que abre hacia abajo así que
las parábolas nunca se intersectan el
sistema de ecuaciones no tiene solución